In this short video, we'll
go through the process
of deploying a Shiny for
Python application from Posit
Workbench.
Here I am in VS Code
to Posit Connect.
So just to give you
a lay of the land.
So what you're
seeing right here is
a Shiny for Python
application called app.py,
and that resides
in a directory I've
created called Shiny for Python.
So to get started,
let's go ahead
and install some packages
we'll need for this workflow.
So I'm going to use pip to
install the Shiny package.
Also rsconnect-python, which
is used to deploy applications
to connect.
And then you can
see this application
depends on two popular
data science packages,
matplotlib and numpy.
So let's make sure we
install those as well.
I believe I already have
these in my environment.
So it should say requirement
already satisfied.
So that's great.
We are in a good spot.
Now, before we deploy to posit
connect, let's just make sure
this application runs
correctly locally
here within VS Code
running on posit Workbench.
So I run Shiny run and the
name of the file app.py
Enter
And we'll get a URL that
I can then click on OK.
And here is our Shiny
for Python application.
It's a simple slider
bar that changes
the number of bins
in the histogram
as I move it left and right.
All right. it appears
to be working well.
And then the last thing we'll
do is go ahead and deploy
it to Posit Connect and
we'll use the rsconnect
package to help with this.
So rsconnect deploy shiny.
You have to give it the
name of the Connect server
you want to deploy to.
So I'll use that -n argument.
And I have the server saved
In my environment as pct_prod
and then just give it the
name of the directory that
houses the app.py file.
I'm currently within
this directory,
so I'll just use the period
as a shorthand and hit Enter.
It'll run through a few checks.
Make sure my
environment is being
captured and recorded
and sent to connect,
to replicate that environment.
And once that is done, it'll
deploy to Posit Connect
and we'll get two URLs
here at the bottom.
I can click on this bottom one
and it will actually bring me
straight to Posit Connect.
And here we have that
same application
running on the Connect
instance, and that
is how you can deploy a
Shiny for Python application
to Posit Connect.